Obviously, everyone's like shocked and
stunned at what happened today, right? I
actually saw I can't show it. I won't
show it. But I was sent by a friend of
mine, a brother in Christ. What does
this cat want, man? What do you want?
This cat distracts me. May the Holy
Spirit give us perfect attentiveness. I
was sent the video. I have it. I can't
play it. I don't want to play it. It was
shocking. It really was. May God give us
perfect contentment, not to ourselves
for numbers. It was shocking. I saw the
video.
Charlie Kirk was there in Utah. I saw
it. You see him speak. You see him react
and he slumps over pushing from his
neck.
I actually saw it.
He you he's talking to the crowd. All of
a sudden, boom. He slumps over
pushing. I knew from the video I told my
friend that shot looks like a death
shot.
From seeing it, it looked like a death
shot. That
he told me that they were able to
contain the blood and he was in critical
condition and that's what we prayed for.
Turned out no. So, it seems like the
sniper, this expert marksman, this
murderer knew where he was aiming at and
I guess he hit his artery and died.
Right now, what's heartbreaking is not
so much for Charlie Kirk because
remember what I've said.
Remember why we are here.
Why we are here? Let me explain to you
why we are here. because we know God is
real. I want you to focus. Help me to
help you. Pray God will reign me in the
spirit will work through me because you
know I have OCD, autism, asberers. I
have Tourette's. You know, I don't want
to stumble so I don't cause you to
stumble. We'll get into some meaty
weighty subjects and open up the Q&A.
But remember, we're here because we
know, not just believe, know God is
real. The God of the Bible is real. That
God is the triune God. that God is the
father, the eternal son who became flesh
from the holy virgin, our queen, our
mother, and the eternal spirit. God is
reality, God is real, God is almighty,
Christ is alive, Christ is not dead.
I've tried to encourage you by giving
you scripture and even modern miracles,
right, near-death experiences to assure
you death is not the end of us. So
Charlie spirit left his body. Charlie
his spirit left his body. That's why you
die. Your spirit leaves your body. I'll
give you some verses. We're going to go
through it. So he's now if you believe
the Lord Jesus Christ has believers in
all the major branches of Christianity.
This again why I really appreciate
I really do
the Catholic Church and any church that
will recognize there are true believers
in all the major branches of
Christianity because God who's a God of
infinite love, compassion, mercy, meets
you where you're at, knows what you
know, knows what you don't know, right?
and he understands
your circumstances and takes that into
consideration. So
I believe and I've said this and I'll
say it again. There are believers in all
the major branches of Christian
Christianity. In fact, I've given you
testimonials,
modern miracles you can verify for
yourself, like Jesus Film Project, where
God is doing miracles, dreams, visions,
and healings through the Jesus Film
Project. You guys know it. I've
documented it. They're evangelicals
because God is a God of infinite love.
He meets you where you're at. And if
this is all you know and you don't know
any better, God is not going to demand
that you pass a theological quiz. If he
demanded that, none of us would pass.
So get rid of the trolls, guys. Be very
strict, mods, because you're going to
get trolls coming in trolling. I don't
have time for that. I don't want to sin
in my anger.
So focus
and don't divide and be distracting or
distracted. Let's focus. So Charlie was
a Zionist in that he believed modern
state of Israel is fulfilling a
prophecy. Of course, you know, I came
out of that. I don't believe that. I
don't accept it.
But the point being is if we require
perfect theology to pass the test. You
have Catholics who don't even know their
faith tradition or poorly catechized.
You have Assyrians like my buddy Sargon
D can confirm. I was going to say like
him, but no, they'll confirm who don't
know their faith. They're poorly
catechized. You have Orthodox who don't
know their faith. In point of fact, if
God required passing a theological test,
most of us and most of the people in
your church are going to go to hell.
So be thankful that the Lord Jesus
doesn't demand theological perfection on
this side of glory because none of us
would make it. None of us would make it,
right? None of us would make it. So
Charlie, if you believe the Bible, his
spirit left his body.
If you believe the Bible, he's alive.
He's under the mercy of the Lord Jesus
Christ, under the grace of the Lord
Jesus Christ. Now whether that means
he'll be now purged
postmortem purggation purified cleanse
and the passionate love of God his
allconsuming
loving fire that purges us of all draws
because he wants us to be absolutely
clean or whether he went straight to the
Lord because he was gunned down. Only
God knows. I don't know that. I don't
know that.
So, the pain isn't Charlie. It's the
fact he's got a young wife. Charlie's
only about 31 years old and two
children. In fact, I just was watching.
They go, "His young daughter was there
in the audience."
His young daughter was there. I assume
both of them were there.
And I assume his wife was there. But I
just heard I was listening. His daughter
was there. His young daughter was there.
That means that moment where she saw her
father
gunned down in his throat. She sees him
lumping, right? Like collapsing.
That image will never be erased from her
mind, her heart until the Lord comes and
heals her.
See,
so I don't know if his son was there. I
just was watching. They go, the daughter
was there.
That means she was there seeing her
father speak and next minute
and gushing from his neck. I don't know.
Damn this world, huh? What a world we
live in that you can gun down with no
conscience, no mercy someone just
because you don't agree with his
political views.
Right?
The whole family was there. Huh? Crack.
See?
Wow.
This is why, brethren,
you have every right to bear arms,
defend yourself as a Christian. God
gives you that right. But at the end of
the day, my brothers and sisters, at the
end of the day, God
has determined when we will leave this
world. Not men, not women, but God. I'll
give you example. They tried to do that
to Donald Trump twice. He survived,
right? Why? Because it wasn't Trump's
time to leave.
Meaning that when God has decided, Sam,
it's time for you to go home. If the
whole world comes to stop me from dying,
they will fail. But if God has decided,
Sam, you're sticking around, if the
whole world comes to kill me, they will
fail because God is real.
So don't be stupid. Don't be lazy. Do
all you can to protect your life, the
life of your loved ones, and be there
when you have a sniper, a madman with a
gun, take him down to protect the lives
of those who are unarmed. Much like what
happened to the young lady, right? Did
you see what happened to the young lady
that her name is Arena? Did you see what
happened there? She's sitting in her
chair. I believe it was in a train late
night. A guy just comes up and then
out of nowhere and she dies
on the train
arena. Yeah. What about that one right
there? She's just sitting mindless. some
scum,
right, who hates white people because of
this racist ideology of these pigs like
Tesaria, scum bastards of Satan who
demonize white people. This guy got up
and just
because she was white,
right? This is the ideology.
Yep. You from Ukraine. Exactly. See
this? What happens? My point is, you
don't be stupid.
You do what you can to protect yourself.
Have your weapons ready, whatever you
need. It's your right. But at the end of
the day,
if it's your time, if the Lord wants to
take you home,
you can have a whole army around you.
You can have the most sophisticated
weaponry, right? automat whatever it is
you're going mister and then you can
have no weapons and someone can have a
weapon but it's not your time and he'll
fail to take you out because ultimately
is the almighty God who says when it's
time for you to go
right yes that's that happened too some
old guy said it's me it's me kill me
kill me but he provided distraction he
wasn't the killer in fact I had
suspected it and I'll give you some
Bible verses.
I had suspected Yeah. Oh yeah. Perfect
example is Satun. The guy took a knife
and he aimed it at her throat. He wanted
to
like
cut her throat. By the grace of the
Almighty God, it was a rainy day. She
had an umbrella and when he went to hit
the knife hit the umbrella,
didn't hit her throat, only cut her eye
cuz it wasn't her time.
Yep. Marmari. Exactly. Another example.
Precisely. All these examples,
right? All these examples. Marmari as
well. So, it is God's will. Here, how
what about Pope Paul? Pope John Paul
when was it a Turkish Muslim who shot at
him didn't die he survived and then he
showed the heart of Christ by visiting
the Muslim who tried to gun him down and
forgave him Pope John Paul. Do you know
that? You guys remember that or you
forgot that story? Jo Pope Jo Pope
Pope John Paul II
remember he was Turkish wasn't he? So he
was a Muslim from what I remember he was
Turkish. Correct.
Shot him to try to kill him to murder
him. Wasn't his time to go. And what did
he do? Went and visit him and forgave
him.
So
point being,
yeah, you can be prepared and be
prepared, but when it's your time, it's
your time, brother. Look at
right, look at
the difference. Donald Trump twice, they
failed to take him out. It wasn't his
time to leave. Charlie Kirk, one shot,
hit him perfectly, and he's gone.
And by the way, yeah, the real shooter,
I don't know if they finally caught him.
I suspect it and I won't be shocked if
I'm right. It is a pro Palestinian
Muslim. I'll I won't be shocked if the
shooter is Muslim and he's pro
Palestinian and he hates Charlie Kirk
for his stance on Israel. Again, I'm not
a prophet. I don't know, but I suspect
it is. In fact, someone sent me a name
that sure sounds Muslim.
In fact, yeah, Protestant believer, you
sent me a name, right? The potential
suspect,
Omar Naj Gallov. See, Omar, that's a
Muhammad name. Omar,
right? And yeah. Anyway, so anyway, keep
that in perspective. Uh, my
shock is
you took this guy out, 31 years old,
front of his family.
Now, what do you think you're going to
accomplish by this?
You just made him a martyr and a hero,
and you've now advanced his cause.
Because you stupid idiots, when you kill
someone for a cause, what you're going
to do is cause now thousands of more to
rise up and carry his banner and advance
his cause. You have not wiped out the
ideology or the cause. That's not how
you do it.
So if you thought by taking him out you
were destroying his ideology. Oh
contrary. Here's the key. Is Charlie
dead? Not if you believe your Bible. If
Moses showed that the dead rise for he
calls Even Moses showed that the dead
rise for he calls the Lord the God of
Abraham and the God of Isaac and the God
of Jacob. He is not the God of the dead
but of the living. For to him all are
alive. Okay. Brothers, sisters, do you
believe the words of Jesus Christ? You
know what that means? Those who've died
in Christ, they're still alive. The Holy
Mother is alive. The apostles are alive.
The prophets are alive. Elijah, Elisha,
Daniel, Shadrach, Meek, Abednego,
they're alive.
Peter is alive. Paul is alive. The holy
saints of the church, the martyrs of the
church, the theologians of the church,
they're alive. They're not dead if you
believe what Jesus said. St. Justin
Martyr is alive. St. Eraeus is alive.
Hippoli, Hippolitus or Hippolitis is
alive.
St. Athanasius is alive. St. Alexander
is alive. St. Augustine, St. Jerome,
they're alive.
St. Sirill of Alexandria,
St. Cyprien, St. Clement, they're alive.
If you believe,
what does that mean? Padre Peio is
alive. St. Kalamos is alive. St. Fina is
alive. St. Teresa is alive. St. George
is alive. Maruigus, Mazite, they're
alive. If you believe,
do you believe? And I'm going to show
you that from the Lord. He's going to
ask Martha that when Lazarus was dead,
they're alive. Do you believe? That
means Charlie Kirk is alive. That means
my mother who died in Christ is alive.
And this leads me to the other one right
here.
John 11 right here. 23:27.
Here you go.
The Lord says to Martha, The Lord says
to Martha
the following. Lazarus had been dead for
4 days. Jesus said to her, "Your brother
will rise again." Martha answered,
"I know he'll rise again the
resurrection last day." That I know. I
know the end. I'm a Jewish woman and
I've been taught by the rabbis from
tradition and scripture. The dead will
be raised physically. And you'll find
that in Daniel 12:2,
read verse three as well. Isaiah 25 6-9,
Isaiah 26:19, just to name a few places.
Okay, focus.
But
she didn't understand what the Lord
meant. You don't have to wait for the
resurrection because I'm here to raise
you spiritually, make you spiritually
alive once again, spiritually resurrect
you so that when your body dies, your
souls will continue to live in perfect
lease in my presence until I come and
raise your bodies. And I'll show you
that.
Martha answered, I know he'll rise
again. the resurrection of the last day.
Jesus said to her, "I am the
resurrection of the life." What do you
mean you're waiting for the resurrection
of the last day? You don't need to wait
for the resurrection last day. You're
looking at the resurrection. The
resurrection is here in your face in the
flesh. I am the resurre the resurrection
who became man. I am the life who became
man. So, you're seeing resurrection
in the flesh.
The resurrection that became flesh that
became man.
Jesus said to her, I am the resurrection
life. The one who believes in me will
live even though they die. Now here, do
you believe this part? Whoever lives by
believing in me will never die.
If you're believing in him till the end,
you can never die ever. So then why do
we speak of them as dead?
Do you believe this? Now this is what he
asks. Do you believe this?
So the Lord says, "Do you believe my
words?" Okay, so Charlie Kirk, if you
believe is not dead. Yes, Lord, she
replied. I believe that you are the
Messiah, the son of God who is to come
into the